we've got some breaking news in the  media world CBS has named Stephen  Colbert the next host of The Late Show  he'll be replacing david letterman who  recently said that he'll be retiring in  2015 a quick announcement by CBS in a  story that many thought might unfold  over a period of several months Colbert  obviously has ties to the family of CBS  because the company has also the part of  the Viacom business obviously has ties  to CBS and that's where Stephen Colbert  show has aired we are looking for  specific still on when exactly he'll  take air on CBS but we can say that CBS  is describing this as a five-year deal  between CBS and Stephen Colbert